so why is all of this happening well the
Democrats have told you for the last
month there's one real reason at the
bottom nobody is above the one other
caveats that of course no one is above
vlog set for anyone who might
potentially vote Democrat in which case
laws are racist and must be ignored
that's you know that is pretty amusing
but here's something even funnier those
articles of impeachment that we just saw
passed order to uphold the law that
nobody is above well neither article
that apparently have just been passed
actually accuses the president of
breaking a specific law huh so why are
we here why are we talking about this
why we devoted 43 minutes so far tonight
to this topic why is the president being
impeached well ask Hakeem Jeffries a
member of Congress from New York as
he'll tell you impeachment is a lot to
do with and you never would have guessed
this by the way has a lot to was slavery
bet you didn't see that coming watch
Hakeem Jeffries explains there are some
who cynically argue that the impeachment
of this president will further divide an
already fractured Union but there is a
difference between division and
clarification slavery once divided the
nation but emancipator's rose up to
clarify that all men are created equally
suffrage once divided the nation but
women rose up to clarify that all voices
must be heard in our democracy there is
a difference between division and
clarification did you hear that did you
understand it no because it was
indecipherable cuz it was dumb and
insane and how do people like that get
power in this country ridiculous people
good question this is democracy so it's
important we ought to be meditating on
it but we're not because we're too
mesmerized by the latest in a series of
absurd farces brought to you in
Washington beginning with Russia then
stormy Daniels now impeachment if you're
a cynical person you might suspect that
all of this was designed from the
beginning to distract you from what's
actually going on and what is actually
going on well what is going
around the world and in this country for
example one among many before it leaves
town for Christmas the Congress will
pass a 2,000 page spending bill that
Dana dis referred to it amounts to about
1.4 trillion dollars what's in that bill
wouldn't you like to know you are too
busy watching impeachment to find out we
took a little time and checked here's a
selection for example thousands of
Liberians from Liberia living in this
country will get a special pathway to
citizenship why how'd that happen don't
ask
it was never debated you had no idea it
was even happening this is your country
you didn't know and of course that was
the point how about the war in
Afghanistan going on now for 18 years
just a few weeks ago the Washington Post
released a massive trove of documents
they revealed that our leaders have been
systematically lying to us about how the
war is failing and has been for more
than a decade that should have been the
scandal of the year instead those
documents are forgotten almost
immediately why thanks to impeachment in
fact in this new spending bill Congress
just voted to keep the money flowing
unimpeded to that failed war four
billion dollars will go to the Afghan
security forces really it's like a joke
we know for dead certain that money will
be wasted the second it gets there the
troops we hire will desert their weapons
will wind up with the Taliban if
anything the money that we send is more
likely to be spent killing American
forces than it is to be turning
Afghanistan into Belgium or whatever the
mission is we have no idea but we know
it's not going to achieve that but
Congress is doing it anyway meanwhile
Congress is in addition to all of that
still busily working to undermine your
constitutional rights the spending bill
currently includes twenty five million
dollars to spend on quote gun violence
research and don't lie to yourself
that's not social science it's money
that will go to ideologically motivated
research with only one purpose giving a
pretext to bureaucrats to reduce your
second Amendment rights do you think
that might bother Democrats because as
you know they spent all
strolling the Constitution how much they
care about it now they're representing
the framers of course they don't care
what the Bill of Rights if it's an
obstacle to their power they're against
it and that category includes both
stubborn constitutional amendments like
the first and second and sitting
presidents congressman Al Green by the
way basically said so today ahead of
Congress just a few minutes ago
impeaching the president on both
articles one and two when green called
for the presidents of peachwood
he didn't mention high crimes and
misdemeanors no he got right to the
point he accused president of
disagreeing with his views on
immigration watch this in the name of
democracy on behalf of the Republic and
for the sake of the many who are
suffering I will vote to impeach and I
encourage my colleagues to do so as well
what does that have to do with articles
1 & 2 what does it have to do with
impeachment if you're confused you don't
know how it works so here's a primer
here's all you need to know when you
oppose the Democratic Party's
immigration plans what you're really
doing is challenging their plan to
accumulate more political power